はい！みなさんこんにちは！はじめしゃちょーじゃない！
ドクターはじめだった！みなさんはぁ、寝ているときどうやって寝ていますか？
一般的な寝方というものは、まぁ、ベット、ベットに布団をひいて寝る
これもまあ、たしかに。
そしてもうひとつ敷布団、ベット無しで敷き布団に布団をひいてそのまんま寝る。
これもまぁたしかに。
まあ、洋風は主にベットの上で寝て、まあ、日本人だから和風の和室とかではよく布団をそのまんまひいて寝るという２パターンの寝方があると思う。
ふふゅうううううううう、あ、よだれ。
２パターンの寝方があると思うんだが。私はそれに違和感を感じておるのだ、日ごろ。
まあ、寝ることによってね、体力も回復するしね、いろんなねこのメリットがあると思うんだけどもね、寝てる間は移動ができない！
時間のロスなのだよ！
私は思いついた、敷き布団のまま移動できれば一番いいのじゃないか。それはつまり寝ながら移動できるということなので時間のロスにもならないし、睡眠時間も確保できる。
つまり移動できる布団を作ることによって、我々は新たな生活を送ることができる
僕はそう思ったわけなのさ！
というわけなのでね、ここにはちょっとでかすぎて持ってこれないんですけど、シングルの敷き布団のサイズの木の板を準備してその木の板の下にこう４っつローラーをつけました。
それがね、また大変だったんですよ。もう、完全にＤ・Ｉ・Ｙ。Ｄｏ！Ｉｔ！Ｙｏｕｒｓｅｌｆ！
ほんとに1からねその～お店のおっちゃんに手伝ってもらいつつねアドバイスをいただきつつ頑張って作ったので！もうね～大変だったんすよ～ドリルでなんかいろいろやってね。
なんかね、久しぶりにそのドクターっぽいことをしたんです。
（ドリルの音）
というわけで今日は敷布団、移動式の敷布団を実際に作ってね、ちょっとねそれでいかほどのものかっていうのをちょっと確かめてみようと思います。
では、いこう！！！
こちらが敷布団の下におくローラー。動く稼動部分になります。
ではさっそくお布団をしいていきましょう！
どう？
あ、きてる！
なんか、ちょうどいいんじゃない？
あ！サイズもちょうどいいじゃん！
こっちを頭にしてこうでしょっ！！よしっ！！！こんな感じかな？
こうゆう感じですかね？
こうかぁ～、寝れる！寝れる！寝れる！！
あ、バッチリだ！ちょ、クッションまできいてる！
（ボイ～ンボイ～ンボイ～ンボイ～ン）ほっ！（ボイ～ンボイ～ンボイ～ンボイ～ン）
はいっ！というわけで！！実際布団で寝ることが可能なので実際にこれでちょっと外で寝れるかどうか試してみたいと思います！
これ、天気も選ばずにまあ寝れるという事がこの布団の魅力ということで。
（動いている音）
あぁ～こいつはいいすね！
あ！！！死ぬ！死ぬ！死ぬ！
いってぇ、これ筋肉、筋肉やべ、これもってかれた、いま
（動いている音）
やぁ～すごい眺めですね～。まさかいつも寝ているその～枕から外の景色が見えるなんて思ってもいなかったんで。
♪～